this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream watch
over 2400 documentaries for free for 31
days a curiosity stream calm Ford / real
engineering on December 12th 1984 the
United States Air Force and NASA began
testing an unusual aircraft one that
broke all aircraft design convention its
wings pointed forward however this
experimental aircraft dubbed the X 29
was not the first of its kind the
Germans also experimented with the
concept in the late stages of world war
two with the Younker ju 287 and its
prototype airframes would eventually end
up in the hands of the soviets who took
and developed the design into the okb-1
EF 131 and the okb-1
140 all of these early iteration designs
ran into the same problems this design
was incredibly aerodynamically unstable
when the wing deflects the force of the
oncoming wind tends to make it deflect
even more this is a rather obvious
design flaw intuitively you know just
looking at it that something doesn't
quite make sense so why did Germany the
Soviet Union and the United States all
see the design worthy for consideration
to understand this we first have to
explore why wings are swept beyond a
perfectly perpendicular angle in the
first place looking at most aircraft
developed during World War 2 you can see
that nearly all of them had straight
wings the Spitfire the Mitsubishi a6m
zero and the p-51 Mustang it was only
during the later stages of the war as
more powerful engines came to the fore
that other designs started to emerge and
in one case the straight wing became a
major design flaw that put the crew of
the p-38 lightning in serious danger
these problems arose directly as a
consequence of how wings generate lift
an aerofoil is designed to make use of
Bernoulli's principle where a
low-pressure zone is created on top of
the wing as a result of airflow moving
faster people like to say this is false
but it's just one of the ways a wing
generates lift there is a lot more to
the story because this airflow actually
speeds up as the cross as the wing is
can reach supersonic speeds long before
the plane itself reaches super
speeds this causes problems because
supersonic flow means shockwaves form
which can disrupt normal airflow over
the wing on November 4th 1941 these
problems resulted in the death of Ralph
Verdun an expert test pilot during a
high-speed test dive of the p-38
lightning the causes of the crash were
all clear at the time this version of
the p38 had been altered with superior
servos for the control surfaces to help
the pilot overcome aerodynamic
stiffening where the force of oncoming
air at high speeds makes it difficult to
move the control surfaces but the plane
still entered an uncontrolled dive
regardless of these measures the
engineers eventually discovered the
airflow was separating from the surface
of the wing as a result of shockwave
formation this reduced the lift the wing
could generate while increasing the lift
on the tail wing directly downstream of
the flow separation this moved the
center of pressure and forced the plane
to pitch downwards and gain even more
speed making it next to impossible to
recover from to solve this issue that
incorporated a die flap on the lower
surface of the wing where airflow was
not reaching supersonic speeds which
could be deployed during high speed
dives to allow the wing to generate lift
and recover from the dive as technology
advanced however aeronautical engineers
started to see that straight wings were
not suitable for transonic and
supersonic speeds and gradually started
to adopt swept wings
the Germans confirmed the theory with
high speed wind tunnel testing in 1939
by testing two wings a straight wing and
a swept wing with a 45 degree sweep
proving that a swept wing would delay
the onset of supersonic flow and reduce
drag they recognized that the swept wing
would allow a plane to fly faster before
shock waves formed long before it the
technology that would enable them to fly
faster was even invented they used this
knowledge to develop the Messersmith
p110 won a jet-powered plane that could
actually change its sweep angle before
flight but the end of the war came
before the Germans could finish it and
test the aircraft and it was captured
and developed into the bell x5 by the
United States to understand the purpose
of sweep angle let's see how air flow
evolves over this
swing as it changes its sweep angle
while comparing flow over a straight
wing air flow over a wing perpendicular
to the free stream air has one component
the chord wise flow which is the air
that flows over the chord of the
aerofoil the chord is the imaginary line
running from the leading edge to the
trailing edge of the aerofoil chord wise
flow does accelerate over the aerofoil
and thus contributes to lowering the
speed at which supersonic flow begins
called the critical Mach number now
let's look at the flow components over
the bell x5s wing at its lowest sweep
angle 20 degrees here we can separate
the airflow into two components the
chord wise flow which is now offset at a
20 degree angle relative to the free
stream and the new second component the
span wise flow which flows along the
length of the wing and does not
accelerate and thus does not lower the
critical Mach number at lower speeds
where supersonic airflow is not a worry
you want as much of that air flow to be
cord wise and thus generate the
necessary lift to fly however as the
speed of the plane begins to climb we
are generating more than enough lift
thanks to the increased airspeed and
thus can afford to convert some of that
air flow into span-wise flow we do this
by increasing the sweep angle which the
bell x5 could do in flight to a maximum
sweep angle of 60 degrees as the sweep
angle increases a larger portion of that
airflow is converted to span-wise flow
which is great for increasing the top
speed of an aircraft but can cause some
troublesome stall characteristics
because a large volume of air is now
originating at the root of the wing and
traveling down to the tip of the wing
stall will begin at the tip of the wing
and move towards the root this is a
problem because their ailerons the
control surfaces that allow us to roll
the plane are located on the outer wing
if stall occurs on the outer wing we
lose roll control a major problem for
say a fighter jet attempting a high
angle of attack maneuver while
maintaining full control and this is one
of the problems Ford swept wings were
trying to fix this reverses the
direction of the chord wise flow so
it originates at the wingtips and
travels to the root of the wing meaning
stall occurs at the root of the wing
first allowing us to maintain control of
the plane for much longer not only that
it also reduced induced drag as a result
of wingtip vortices where high pressure
air from the lower wing travels and
mixes with low-pressure air on top of
the wing at the wingtips
the ju 287 was designed this way not to
benefit from the superior aerodynamic
characteristics but to move the wing box
rear words which allowed the bombe to
move forward closer to the center of
gravity of the aircraft which in turn
allowed the plane to carry a larger bomb
while not increasing the trim drag to
keep the plane balanced but ultimately
the materials at the time could not
facilitate it under normal wing loading
the main force being exerted on the wing
is upwards bending where the force of
lift pushes the wing upwards while the
weight of the fuselage pushes downwards
to survive this we need to build an
adequately strong and stiff wing this is
achieved through a beam called a spur
which runs the length of the wing with a
forward swept wing an additional stress
is introduced where the force of
oncoming air is attempting to twist the
wing we can imagine this with a free
body diagram with the springs
representing the stiffness we need to
incorporate into the wing here KB is the
spring stiffness that will be needed to
resist bending and KT is the spring
stiffness needed to resist twisting
creating a structural member that can
act like this torsion spring over the
entire wing however is no easy task and
would require enough additional weight
to negate any positive attributes the
fourth swept wing would provide but that
changed when advanced composite
materials became available allowing
planes like the X 29 and the Russian
equivalent the su-47 to be made both
planes use carbon fiber reinforced
plastics laid up so the fibers would
resist a twisting motion I will focus on
the X 29 from here as information on
American technology is far more freely
available the X 29 s primary structural
member for resisting this twist was a
closed box section located here which
was constructed of criss-crossed
composit tape that reached up to 156
layers deep essentially creating that
spiral spring shape within the
structural member
but with extremely stiff and lightweight
composites taming that twisting motion
and allowing the plane to fly
successfully wind tunnel tests showed
that the forward swept design would
provide a 20% gain in efficiency
compared to the same plane with aft
swept wings this along with a
supercritical wing design which flattens
the top edge of the aerofoil to minimize
the acceleration of air over the top
edge while introducing a concave curve
to the lower surface to increase lift
allowed the X 29 to spend less fuel
flying at a higher Mach number another
drag reducing benefit of the forward
swept wing was the shifting of the
center of pressure rear words typically
the lift generated by an after swept
wing needs to be counteracted by a tail
wing which generates downwards pressure
to maintain pitch stability this
downwards pressure is wasted energy that
contributes to drag with a forward swept
wing the center of pressure is moved to
the rear of the aircraft behind the
center of gravity and thus to maintain
static pitch control these pitch control
services called canards need to generate
lift forward of the center of gravity
and thus contribute to useful lift this
would seem like an obvious feature to
incorporate into every aircraft but
leads to instability that requires two
control surfaces to constantly adjust to
maintain stable flight and this was one
of the massive challenges the designers
faced the x-29 was incredibly unstable
especially in pitch even when compared
to modern jet fighters
this means the flight control computers
had to be constantly adjusting the
control surfaces to maintain stable
flight about 40 times a second to do
this the x-29 had three flight control
computers to provide redundancy if one
failed as the plane would become
essentially impossible to fly without
the aid of computer which made it even
more worrying when all three shut down
while preparing to take off this caused
the plane to be grounded delaying
testing which was due to accelerate
with the arrival of a second x-29 fitted
with a parachute system to allow high
angle of attack manoeuvres to be safely
tested the spin parachute was installed
to provide positive recovery from spins
as Windtunnel tests had indicated that
the x-29 ailerons and rudder provided
poor recovery from fully developed
upright spins eventually the problems
were solved in high angle of attack
testing resumed improved the x29 s
capabilities but the program ultimately
ended on December 8 1988 almost four
years to the day of its first flight in
between that first and last flight the
x-29 completed 242 flights with 179
combined flight hours providing valuable
scientific data and design experience in
composite airframes and computer aided
flight ultimately Ford swept wings
weren't incorporated into newer
generations of planes as the benefits
simply did not outweigh the cons from
the additional structural requirements
the poor pitch stability and perhaps
most importantly its negative effects on
stealth design in the end off swept
Delta wings won out this is just one of
many unusual plane designs that
originated in world war ii era germany
among other novel military vehicles you
can learn more about these innovative
machines with this documentary titled
Hitler's miracle machines on curiosity
Street you can watch it for free by
signing up to curiosity stream using the
code real engineering and using the link
in the description this will give you a
month of completely free access to over
2,400 documentaries and nonfiction
titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers after that first free month
you can continue your access for just
$2.99 for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter discord server and
subreddit are below
you